pour la défense de l'environnement d'ici
à 2010 la france doit augmenter jusqu'à
20% sa part d'électricité issue des
énergies renouvelables c'est une
directive européenne évoquant cette
initiative intéressante nous nous
rendons dans un tout nouveau village
situé près de perpignan qui a fait le
choix du solaire dominique dumas
nathalie berthier se sont rendus sur
place des panneaux solaires comme celui
ci il en sera installé encore des
dizaines dans ce lotissement de saint
cyprien électricité et eau chaude
solaire sont à la disposition des
habitants de ce nouveau village d'une
centaine de maisons et de 200 logements
collectifs
ici les techniciens recorte un chauffe
eau solaire thermique de 300 litres pour
une seule famille mais pour pauline et
maïlys qui rentre de la plage peu
importe si cette eau est chauffée grâce
au solaire leurs parents ont été séduits
pour eux les énergies renouvelables
comme le solaire devrait être avantagé
sont moins besoin d'apports d'énergie
effectivement les solutions alternatives
peuvent suffire à nos propres demandes
de l'eau chaude certes mais ces panneaux
solaires produisent également de
l'électricité pour les parties communes
l'éclairage des rues ne coûte rien aux
habitants et c'est une contribution à la
lutte contre l'effet de serre l'enjeu
principal est que le bâtiment est
responsable de 25 % des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre de gaz carbonique et
dans l'ain jeu aujourd'hui c'est de
faire des bâtiments qu'on appelle
bâtiment à énergie positive qui
produisent plus d'énergie qu'il n'en
consommera ce lotissement est l'un des
plus importants projets solaires de
france
pour le promoteur suisse il s'agit
également de déclencher le bon réflexe
en matière d'environnement constructeur
à mes yeux en tout cas une véritable
responsabilité par rapport aussi au
réseau générations futures
et je crois que c'est avant tout cet
élément qui est primordial dans le cadre
du choix du solaire des énergies
renouvelables les douches public chauffé
au solaire la dernière innovation dans
ce village est le symbole d'une volonté
de changer les mentalités dans la vie de
tous les jours
le plan climat prévoit un million de
mètres carrés de panneaux solaires pour
2005 alors que le prix du pétrole est
instable énergies renouvelables rime
vraiment avec indispensable